Land und
[Musik]
prcht schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus na wo erreich ich dich ich
war gerade dabei dir die Frage zu
stellen aber ich weiß warum
du denkst ich bin noch in der Ukraine
ich bin zurück okay wir sind zurück wir
sind seit seit jetzt zwei Tagen zurück
ich ich hatte ein ihres Erlebnis heute
Nacht und auch in der Nacht davor ich
habe vergessen meine meine App zu
deaktivieren meine Air Alert app also
die den Luft den Luftalarm das heißt du
hast immer noch alarmwarnrufe bekommen
ja ja und das ist krass ich ich weißt du
was ich dachte wenn du mal ein Gefühl
dafür kriegen willst was dieser Krieg
ist welche Belastung das ist wie
anstrengend das ist wie mürbe das die
Leute macht dann installierere die mal
diese App Air Alert heißt die und schalt
mal bestimmte Gebiete ein mach mal
aktivi mal Odessa Großraum Odessa
aktiviere mal den Oblast mikolajev
aktivi mal den Oblast herson und so
weiter alles was es da so gibt ich
glaube das ist sogar eins
und und dann wirst du alle
paar Minuten oder vielleicht auch
Stunden wirst du schreckst du hoch weil
dieses Ding dich plötzlich Anja und du
weiß das ist so eine Art Sirene gruselig
ja ist eine Sirene und das hier habe ich
dir mal aufgenommen das ist der Sound
dieser Sirenen die dich nachts aus dem
Schlaf reißen das ist
unheimlich jede Nacht geht das so
mehrfach und dann sagt ihr so eine
Stimme proceed to the nearest Shelter ja
so gehen in den nächsten luftkeller und
so weiter und dann geht's eigentlich
darum wir hatten auch immer so eine
Vorstellung ne wenn man Luftalarm hört
direkt rein irgendwo Bunker
verschwindest irgendwo in der Erde oder
in irgendeinem Keller und so weiter aber
darum geht's eigentlich gar nicht
sondern es geht darum einen sicheren
Raum zu finden und sicher ist klar
definiert sicher bedeutet Versuch
mindestens zwei Wände zwischen dich und
die Außenwelt zu bringen ich frage mich
deswegen liegen Leute häufig auf dem
Korridor z.B ja also wir haben viel Zeit
auf Korridoren verbracht im Korridor
einfach geschla ich mE das Land kann ja
auch nicht komplett mit Luftschutz
Bunkern ausgestattet sein oder gen genau
genau genau so ist es und dann hast du
z.B in unserem Hotel mikolai war so die
die die erste Etage komplett zugenagelt
das Erdgeschoss komplett zugenagelt ja
also einfach alles und dann dann bist du
ich ich bin am ersten Morgen gar nicht
wach geworden weil weil es nicht hell
wurde bis ich dann irgendwann gerafft
habe ach so mein ganzes Zimmer ist ja
vernagelt ist einfach zu einfach zu mit
irem Sperrholz und so weiter einfach um
zu vermeiden dass im Zweifel glass
spittert irgendwas reindonnert die
schwer verletzt und so weiter das muss
ja nicht mal die Bombe oder die Rakete
selber sein sondern es sind diese diese
schrapnels vor denen die wahnsinnige
Angst haben das sind dann irgendwelche
Splitter das kann ein Metallteil der
Bombe sein das kann ein Metallteil aber
auch eines Pflasterstein ein einen Teil
eines plasterstein was die
mombe genau genau und dann geht das mit
einer unfassbaren Geschwindigkeit und im
Seif auch durch deinen Kopf oder dein
Körper hab den habt ihr denn in
unmittelmaß der Nähe Detonationen erlebt
ja haben haben wir erlebt ja also was
man versteht das ist interessant also es
ist je nachdem wo man ist also wenn du
jetzt gerade nach z.B reingehst wir sind
dann dort immer nicht mehr rein sind 4
km vor der Stadt geblieben weil
genau in der Zeit in der wir da waren
die Stadt massiv unter Feuer lag und der
das der der codesatz dafür war immer es
ist gerade sehr laut in in chason und
als wir dann da rausfuhren es war gab
vorher noch so eine Begebenheit wir
haben Frauen interviewt Soldatinnen
interviewt und das
das auch das gehört zu den zu den Dingen
dieses Krieges die ich bis dato
zumindest nicht verstanden hatte wie
viele Frauen auch in diesem Krieg ihren
Dienst machen dann und dann steht da
eine Frau mit mit lackierten
Fingernägeln und einer Kalaschnikov in
der Hand ja in in in in
camouflagefarbener Uniform und so weiter
und dann ist es natürlich extrem
interessant zu fragen was hast Du denn
vor gemacht und dann war sie
supermarktleiterin oder hat ein
Nagelstudio oder solche Dinge daher auch
dann diese Fingernägel z.B und dann
darfst du die zweite Frage am besten
nicht stellen aber natürlich muss man
sie eigentlich stellen h du Kinder wo
sind diese Kinder wie groß ist die Sorge
um diese Kinder dann die ganz harte
Frage wo ist eigentlich gerade dein Mann
und die Antwort ist immer der ist gerade
an der Front und wir machen uns
wahnsinnige sorgen und so weiter und
dann kam einer der Verantwortlichen mit
in diesem Interview kam dann an und
sagte pass auf wir müssen jetzt hier weg
die wurden ganz unruhig und ich sagt
warum was ist hier los ja wir werden
gerade gesehen wir werden beobachtet die
Russen haben uns jetzt auf dem Radar die
wissen dass wir hier sind wir sind zu
viele Autos zu viele Menschen zu viel
Auflauf da ist die Versuchung
unglaublich groß ne die wirst mit so
drohen ausisches Ziel genau wirst du
wirst du ein Ziel und die die Drohne
also sind zwei Drohnen oder mehrere
drohen in der Luft die eine spioniert
dich aus mit hochaulösenden Kameras und
gibt dann sozusagen der anderen die auch
schon neben ihr quasi in der Luft
schwebt gibt der die Position durch und
es das dauert Millisekunden ja von von
dem Moment wo die Position fixiert ist
bis zu der Sekunde wo dann das das
Geschoss kommt das ist Wahnsinn und dann
sind wir da raus fahren aus dieser aus
dieser Stadt und dann schlug es
plötzlich links ein stieg irgendwo eine
Rauchsäule auf und dann plötzlich schlug
es auch rechts ein stieg weit entfernt
eine Rauchsäule auf als schwarzer Rauch
und da merkst du plötzlich ach so
linkseinschlag Rechtseinschlag und wir
genau dazwischen mhm und das ist der
Moment wo du dann merkst okay es stimmt
was mir schon ganz zu Beginn ein ein
junger Mann in der Westukraine die aus
unserer Sicht eigentlich ziemlich
sicheres Gebiet ist sagte es gibt keinen
sicheren Ort in der Ukraine es gibt
keinen fühle ich nirgendwo wirklich
sicher und deswegen ist dieser dieser
Air Alert dieser
Luftalarm das macht was mit dir D dein
Herz geht hoch auf einew du bist im
Tiefschlaf und dann bom bom bom bom bom
kommt dieses Ding und irgendwann wird
dann Entwarnung gegeben das dauert
manchmal 20 Minuten manchmal 40 Minuten
manchmal eine Stunde manchmal zwei dann
erfährst du drohen steigen gerade auf
über dem über dem Schwarzen Meer
meistens diese ekelhaften scharits von
den mullas aus aus aus
an genau und oder oder es ist irgendein
ein eine dieser dieser fiesen gelenkten
Raketen oder Bomben unterwegs und so
weiter und dann kommt am Ende immer das
ist auch irre kommt dann kommt dann wenn
wenn der Alarm vorbei ist kommt eine
Stimme so eine tiefe Hollywood Stimme
und sagt may the force be with you ja
möge die Macht mit hier sein Obi van
kinobi star wars ja das ist so sehr
professionell gemacht und ich fand es
erst dachte was ist das für ein Schrott
und irgendwie fand ich dann schön dass
dieser Mann den ich nicht kenne und der
mir nicht näher bekannt ist ja mir dann
immer so tröstend diese Worte zuriief
und sagte junge es ist alles wieder gut
es ist man hält sich dann an so kleinen
Dingen plötzlich fest völlig völlig
bescheuert aber es ist wichtig aber das
ist
ja das ist das war so also wir haben uns
ja in Kiev gesprochen Richard und dann
der Weg da noch mal tiefer rein also
dieses vergleichsweise normale Leben in
Kiev zu sehen das sind ja gerade die
Außenminister da die Leute fragen immer
wie kommt man da rein da gibt's
Autobahnen die sind erstaunlich gut in
Schuss viele viele Straßen also ich habe
in Moldau z.B schlechtere Straßen zum
Teil erlebt z.B die reih nach gagausien
ist die deutlich schlechtere Straße als
die große lange Straße nach Kiev rein
und dann kommst du immer weiter Richtung
Osten Richtung Süden sind dem Nachtzug
dann da tief in die Nacht re mit dem Zug
dann darüber und dann merkst Du
plötzlich wie alles anders wird dann
kommst Du da in live an fährst dann
durch so eine Straße komplett dunkel
keine Straßenlaterne die leuchtet hab
ein bestimmten Uhrzeit h einen Mann
gesehen auch fotografiert der führte
seinen Hund mit mit seinem iPhone der
Taschenlampe vom iPhone an Gassi Front
ungefähr 40 km entfernt und da wird die
dann schon anders da merkst du plötzlich
okay alles klar hier hier sind wir jetzt
in Reichweite und hier gibt es wirklich
kein sicher nordmer wie ist das in in
Odessa selber also in Kiev hast du
beschrieben wenn jetzt der Luftalarm
nicht wäre sagen wir mal wenn du einfach
nur so von nichts was wüsstest und
einfach ein Tag dort verbringen würdest
du nicht wissen dass Krieg ist ne obwohl
Krieg ist richtig wie ist das in
Odessa in Odessa ist es in gewisser
Weise ähnlich aber Odessa ist natürlich
wahnsinnig exponiert weil Odessa liegt
direkt am Schwarzen Meer das heißt die
russischen Schiffe sind nicht weit weg
100 km 20000 km weit weg und sehr sehr
schnell zu erreichen durch diese Raketen
teil Weise mach dre ja oder bis zu Mach
3 also dreimal sch he also wenn wenn
wenn so eine Rakete abgefeuert ist die
ist wahnsinnig keine vorwahenzeit genau
es geht irre schnell es geht so schnell
dass du kaum schance die habombardements
gelten so weiß ich das aus den
Nachrichten weiß meistens dem Hafen
Hafen genau da kommst du auch nicht so
richtig ran wir haben ich habe dieses
Hotel gesehen dass sie gerade letzte
Woche getroffen haben das ein ganzer
Turm einfach da ragt weißt du wie so ein
wie so ein wie so ein wie so ein
kaputter verfaulter Zahn ragt das dann
so einfach in den Himmel das das sieht
irre aus und die die die die weißt du
das ist vorbei und kaputt und zerstört
in einer Millisekunde das haben aber
Menschen vorher wahrscheinlich zwei
Jahre lang aufgebaut und es bauen wieder
jetzt Menschen zwei Jahre lang auf ja
ich frage mich immer steht da überhaupt
noch was da steht also wie groß muss
muss ein Hafen sein ne der der ständig
unter Dauerbeschuss steht und mit Mörder
Raketen da beschossen wird dass dieser
Hafen offensichtlich doch irgendwie noch
als Hafen funktioniert ja es wird ja es
wird ja immer wieder er die versuchen ja
viel jetzt auch gerade wieder es ist
Teil dieses zynischen Spiels wirklich
Infrastruktur zu zerstören ne jetzt
geht's auf den Winter zu und wie
zufällig zerstört man jetzt
Energieversorgung Heizwerke und so
weiter ja die Leute sollen frieren die
sollen es kalt haben die sollen es
ungemütlich haben da geht's ganz viel um
psychologische Kriegsführung die die
Botschaft ist immer fühlt euch nicht
sicher und wenn ihr dennoch es schafft
irgendwie zu überleben wir werden es
euch so ungemütlich wie möglich machen
aber es ist doch die gleiche Strategie
die die Alliierten gegen Deutschland im
Zweiten Weltkrieg gemacht
machench die deutchen Stdte bombardieren
ne und wie jeder weiß ist diese
Strategie nicht auf richtig die ging
noch nie auf es ist also nicht so
gewesen als ob dann daraufhin die
deutsche Bevölkerung irgendwie gegen die
Nazis rebelliert hätte oder oder Hitler
in den Rücken gefallen wäre oder so
sondern im Gegenteil ne ist so das
zusammenhaltsgefühl und diese
Entschlossenheit und dieses erbitterte
wir müssen durchhalten und so weiter das
stand ja viel mehr im Vordergrund als
jetzt ein Zweifel genau an diesem
kriegtig und deswegen frage ich mich
warum die Russen eine Strategie
verfolgen die da schon über Jahre hinweg
Zweiten Weltkrieg überhaupt nicht
funktioniert hat genau die die die Nazis
auch so erfolglos in England praktiziert
haben
ne gib Bücher darüber genau also
angefangen haben ja bei diesen diesen
bombardems tatsächlich die Nazis als man
Coventry bombardiert hat man wollte der
Zivilbevölkerung möglichst größte Angst
machen damit die Engländer aufgeben so
und umgekehrt wollten die die Engländer
mit ihren bombardems die am und bomb
auch die Moral der deutschen brechen
richtig und tatsächlich ist der der
Krieg in Stalingrad verloren worden aber
er ist nicht verloren worden durch die
Bombardements der Alliierten an der
Heimatfront genau und das wiederholt
sich da an dem Punkt dass das fand ich
so erstaunlich also mit welcher
trotzigkeit ja die Leute versuchen
sozusagen weiterhin Normalität zu leben
bis zu dem Punkt du kannst dir nicht
vorstellen wie viele abgeschleppte Autos
wie viele abgeschleppte Karren ich in
Kiev gesehen habe sehe ich in Hamburg
also dafür no Zeit nee das wird gemacht
Tickets schreiben Karren Abschleppen wer
schrottig parkt wird abgeschleppt und du
denkst warte mal Freunde ihr habt doch
hier gerade ein ganz anderes Thema ihr
seid doch im Krieg nee wichtig um
Normalität zu haben und zu leben und das
ist auch Teil dieser trotzigkeit mit mit
der die daangehen das das war fand ich
ganz ganz erstaunlich ja Autos
abschleppen und Tickets schreiben mitten
im Krieg entlich Ordnung zu wen richtig
richtig es muss für die Menschen sich
einigermaßen normal anfühlen und ich
fühlte mich erinnert an diesen Bericht
weiß noch ich habe es mir so hängen
geblieben einen Satz von einem
englischen Händler als als die richtig
also äh der der der der östliche Teil
von von London als die so richtig unter
Beschuss waren der Nazis und die Leute
haben trotz sich ihre Geschäfte weiter
aufgemacht und ein Händler der gerade
frisch getroffen von so einer Bombe die
halbe Hütte Weg weggeflogen der dann ein
Schild draußen dran hängt an an seinen
Laden und sagt heute besonders weit
geöffnet ja einfach weitermach heute
besonders zweit geöffnet und das ist
diese trotzigkeit die du auch in der
Ukraine hast wir waren in in ähm wo war
das denn in Odessa
äh da du musst wissen ungefähr 30% so
schätzt man der russischen RAK sind
Blindgänger das heißt auch wenn
du du überlegst dir ja was könnte
getroffen werden du hst okay die gehen
auf Infrastruktur die gehen auf Hafen
die gehen auf bestimmte Hotels oder so
Versuch große Menschenansammlungen zu
vermeiden all diese Dinge aber wenn 30
Proz blinkgänger sind dann weißt Du
schlicht nicht und es gibt da diese eine
Rakete die die direkt in ein Wohnhaus
reinballert Nacht zum eins und wir haben
zufällig ein manda getroffen da kam mit
seiner kleinen Tochter da um die Ecke
der erzählte von dieser Nacht der sagt
ich kam gerade aus aus Odessa nach Hause
der war auf Geschäftsreise und er sagt
und ich überall lagen Teile von Menschen
Beine Arme Köpfe Körper lag da einfach
rum in diesem rauchenden Haus da starben
glaub 20 Leute die da drin geschlafen
hatten und ein Teil dieses Hauses steht
noch und ich gehe rein in dieses Haus
und fotografiere unten im Keller dies
dies dieses Trümmerfeld und plötzlich
höre ich von oben Schritte dog dog
dog langsam und denke okay langsame
Schritte es muss ein alter Mensch sein
und warte ganz gespannt wer da jetzt
auftaucht und wenig später erscheint von
mir eine sehr sehr Frau über 80 Jahre
alt auf dem Weg zum Einkaufen und sagt
auf die Frage ob sie da war in der Nacht
ja klar war sie da und warum sie dort
lebt wo soll ich den sonst hingehen mm
das war ihre das war ein so syrealer
Moment und das sind diese Dinge
die diese Kleinigkeiten aber die dich
dann irgendwann verstehen lassen was
dieser Krieg eigentlich wirklich ist ich
noch mal ne ich habe das ja letztes mal
schon gesagt ich will mich überhaupt
nicht jetzt als großer Ukraine Experte
uns ging nur darum ein Gefühl dafür zu
kriegen was dieser Krieg mit einer
Gesellschaft macht eiglich der erste
Krieg oder der erste kriegsschaplatz das
erste Kriegsgeschehen ich meine du hast
ja bist ja viel gereist hast vi
fotografiert bist du vorher schon in
einem Land in dem tatsächlich ein Krieg
tobt gewesen also nicht aktiv genau das
ist der große Unterschied nicht aktiv
ich war oft in Gebieten in den es Krieg
gab und wo das Leben auch nicht sicher
ist ich habe im Kopf auch viele
Parallelen z. zu Israel gesehen es gibt
ja ganze Generationen von von Israelis
die z.B auch gerade meine Generation ne
wenn man gibt ja wenn du dich erinst gab
die Diskussionen dieser dieser
Grenzmauern dieser harten Mauern die
aufgebaut worden sind in belehem z.B wo
dann teilweise so so absurde Mauern
einfach komplett quer durch die Stadt
gehen und wir als Deutsche sind
natürlich bei Mauern immer besonders
sensibel und sagen wie wie grausam und
unmenschlich ist das wo du teilweise
Familien getrennt hast ja ich ich
erinere mich an einen Ort da ist auch
das ähm das Hotel von von von BSI ja dem
dem Graffiti Star dem großen
Graffitikünstler der hat ein Hotel
direkt an dieser Mauer und da gibt's ein
Haus das ist von drei Seiten von dieser
Mauer eingekeilt in belehem und
auf der anderen Seite der Mauer lebten
Bekannte und Verwandte von der Familie
die ich dies alss der Mauer gesprochen
habe und die sagten du früher waren wir
in 30 Sekunden bei unseren Freund und
jetzt brauchen wir 3 Stunden und mehrere
Checkpoints und so weiter um
dahinzukommen und wie wie wie
unmenschlich und grausam ist das
eigentlich wenn du dann auf der anderen
Seite bist redest du mit Israelis z.B
meiner
Generation die aufgewachsen sind immer
wenn sie als Kinder als Schüler zu einer
Bushaltestelle gelaufen sind mit dem
mulmigen Gefühl was passiert hier als
nächstes geht wieder in eine Bombe hoch
an dieser Bushaltestelle explodiert sie
im Bus werde ich diese Busfahrt diese
triviale Busfahrt werde ich die
überleben schlicht und ergreifend und
seitdem es diese Mauer da gibt hat das
signifikant abgenommen der hat natürlich
eine völlig andere Perspektive auf diese
Mauer als ein junger Palästinenser der
auf der anderen Seite sitzt und sagt sag
mal wo soll ich denn hin und wo ist denn
eine Perspektive für mein eigenes Leben
ne und so und und so entfremdet sich das
immer weiter und man kennt sich ir nicht
mehr und es wird einfach nur noch
traurig und und und und das ist das wo
ich das Gefühl habe dass das könnte auch
in der Ukraine passieren wir haben eine
eine wenn du da mal reingehst ne die
Männer z.B will die aus diesem Krieg
zurückkommen wie sehr die sich verändern
ich habe mich ja mit einem
Schriftsteller gesprochen der ist jetzt
zuständig für Kriegsgefangenen Austausch
ja ich mE es war ein Kollege von dir sag
was hast du vor dem Krieg gemacht sagt
ja ich war Schriftsteller tolle Bücher
gemacht und so weiter und der ist jetzt
der ist jetzt im kriegsmodus und und
erzählt dann von der Art und Weise wie
dieser Kriegsgefangenen Austausch
organisiert wird und wie sie manchmal
russische Kriegsgefangene die in einem
besonders bedauernwerten Zustand sind
einfach einfach ohne Bedingungen einfach
zurückschicken in der Hoffnung dass von
der anderen Seite
auchichiert genau und es passiert aber
nicht es passiert nicht und sagt das ist
das was uns so verstört und das ist das
wo wir mit unserem mit unserem wie soll
man sagen empathischen Zugang das war
ein sehr zugewandter empathischer Mann
ja als Schriftsteller ist immer toll mit
Schriftstellern zu reden deswegen rede
ich auch so gerne mit Dir ja wirklich
weil es sind Leute die Dinge durchdenken
und durchdringen ja es macht immer
großen Spaß und das war auch so einer
und
äh dann erzählt dir diese Sachen und du
denkst Alter wie soll denn das jemals
werden das das das das geht einfach
nicht mehr und da merkst du wie sich
Gesellschaft verändert oder w man eine
sniperin getroffen eine Scharfschützin
ja auch so ein absurdes Bild wir gehen
in dieses in auf diesen auf dieses
Gelände lebt ein bisschen außerhalb von
Kiev ist in der Ukraine weltberühmt
sozusagen ein Instagram Account ist ist
jemand den in Ukraine jeder kenntm sie
beant anwortte dir nicht die Frage wie
viele Russen sie erschossen hat und sagt
das ist eine Frage die ja stellen immer
nur stellen immer nur Journalisten und
sagt dann und da merkst du auch wie sich
Sprache verändert weißt du Markus ich
erschieße keine Menschen ich erschieße
nur Gegner ja ich erschieße keine
Menschen ich verteidige die Ukraine das
sind so Sätze ne mit denen man sich
sozusagen und dann sag ich zu ihr aber
ganz ehrlich du guckst da durch dieses
Zielfernrohr du siehst den du kennst den
irgendwann du weißt wie der lacht du
weißt wie der ist du weißt du weißt du
du weißt ein bisschen ob das ein netter
Kerl ist oder ob das ein ob das ein
Arschloch Delux ist wie du sagen würdest
und dann drückst du irgendwann ab und
dann siehst Du weil das geht so schnell
du siehst was dieser diese Kugel mit dem
jetzt macht du sprengst sein ganzes
Gesicht weg mhm sagt sie ja ich habe
jetzt ein Kind bekommen ich kann das
nicht mehr also da da da da da da fällt
ne merkst auch das verändert die Leute
und dann hat sie sich verliebt in einen
Mann der dann auch wier an die an die
Front ging und so weiter und dann kommt
der zurück und vermöbelt die nach allen
Regeln der Kunst häusliche Gewalt
riesiges Thema Dasch zweiten wel diese
Verrohung der
Gesellschaft dem dem waren wir so auf
der Spur und das war natürlich war
beklemmend das zu sehen weil du weißt
das ist ein Thema das löst du nicht
jetzt einfach indem du sagst okay jetzt
Waffenstillstand und mal Ruhe dann ist
das bleib über Jahrzehnte genau genau
genau du wollst gerade sagen zweiter
weltkrieg na ja es ist ja große
parallele ne also wie viele wie viele
Männer sind als seelengrüppe aus dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg zurückgekommen konnten
nicht darüber sprechen genau wollten
meistens auch nicht darüber sprechen sie
gehörten noch einer Generation an die
ohnehin nicht über Gefühle geredet hat
damals genau dann konnten sie nicht
davon ausgehen dass die Leute die hier
geblieben sind irgendein Verständnis
dafür hatten sie hatten Dinge gesehen
oder auch Dinge getan wo sie sich in
ihren Künsten Träumen nicht hatten
vorstellen können dass sie das tun
konnten natürlich aus der Logik heraus
die in einem Krieg herrscht dass der
andere kein Mensch ist sondern ein
Gegner ein Gegner und ich ver Gegner
aber das ist in dem Moment das ist in
dem Moment aber ist er das noch 5 Jahre
später genau wenn du darüber nachdenkst
und dann noch vielleicht D ein Lachen
vor Augen hast oder wie auch immer als
Scharfschütze oder was es auch immer ist
das heißt also nur in der
Kriegssituation das geht ja auch gar
nicht anders ja wird der Gegner zum
Gegner entmenschlich ja und wird
entmenschlich genau ist der Punk aber
aber aber im Grund irwn irgendwann kommt
ja komm kommt die Menschlichkeit ja ja
wieder wenn die Kriegssituation Weg ist
also wenn dieser Rahmen der die Menschen
in menschlicht wenn der Weg ist dann
werden sie auch irgendwann wieder zu
Menschen genau dann bist du der Mensch
der Menschen getötet hat und nicht
Gegner und damit fertig zu werden es
gibt Leute die werden damit fertig ich
weiß nicht ob sie die besseren
Charaktere sind und diejenigen die
zerbrechen innerlich daran und ich meine
gar nicht drüber nachdenken all die die
kriegstraumatisierten nicht nur die
körperlich kriegsversierten sondern die
ganzen seelisch kriegsversierten Zweiten
Weltkrieg ja die Kinder die Kinder vor
allen Dingen ne das habe ich da auch
noch mal verstanden ne die haben alle
Kinder also es ist du du sprichst mit
mit diesen Frauen du sprichst mit diesen
Männern du stellst die Frage bist du
verheiratet ja klar hast du Familie ja
klar hast du Kinder ja klar wie gehen
die damit um und die die Geschichte die
du hörst ist immer wieder die gleiche ne
dann kracht's irgendwo laut dann fangen
die Kinder hysterisch anzuschreien weil
sie wissen was das bedeutet so schwer
ist traumatisierte Kinder und das das
das verändert natürlich dieses dieses
unbeschwerte aufwachsen dass jedes Kind
haben sollte ja das das gibt's dann
einfach nicht mehr natürlich ja und
nachher ein glücklicher Mensch zu werden
ne ein sozialer Mensch und alles was
dazu gehört ich hatte ich hatte Richard
üens erinnerst du dich an deine letzte
Frage du hast du hast mir einen Auftrag
mitgegeben erinnerst du dich daran du
hast mir gesagt Fragen Bauern ja in der
südostukraine was er über diesen Krieg
denkt ja ich ich ich ich ich dachte
einfach dass man mit den Menschen redet
auf deren Gelände auf deren Gelände der
Krieg ausgetragen richtig genau habe ich
getroffen okay in der in der Nähe also
zwischen hersonn und mikolajev waren wir
in in som Dorf und davon muss ich dir
kurz erzählen das
war du fährst von dieser Hauptstraße weg
du siehst links so ein komisches
Fahrzeug das ganz viel Staub
aufwirbelt denkst was ist denn das für
für ein Ding und da merkst du immer da
sitzt gar keiner drin ist wie so ein wie
so ein wie so ein großer Mähdrescher
sozusagen ja dann siehst du so ein Bus
irendwo stehen und da drin sitzt der Typ
der den steuert das ein Roboter der
entmient weil in diesem Gebiet das ist
das vermienteste Gebiet das es auf der
Welt im Moment gibt es gibt kein Gebiet
auf diesem Planeten das so der Art
vermient ist wie genau das Minen in
allen denkbaren Formen ich glaube 38 39
40 verschiedene Typen gibt's dann so
haben wir schon mal drüber gesprochen ne
gibt's dann so diese diese diese
panzermenen dann gibt's die Minen auf
die du die du drauf trittst dann springt
die erstmal ein Stück hoch damit die
dann so auf auf in der Mitte deines
Körpers ungefähr ist ja so auf der
Gürtel Gürtelhöhe quasi und dann exp t
das Ding erst richtig um dich maximal
kaputt zu machen das ist die simple Idee
davon dann gibt es Minen die aussehen
wie so so bunte Bonbons quasi Kinder
fassen die an so kleine Dinger die die
regnen so runter einfach kommen was du
so und die fassen die an und dann geht
das Ding hoch schwer verletzt kannst
auch verbluten natürlich ja
Krankenhäuser die dann weit weg sind das
ist so kann nicht drüber nachdenken was
sind das für Menschen ja also die
Ingenieure die sowas konstruieren und
wir wissen das wird ja nicht nur in
Russland hergestellt ja also solches
mördergerät wird überall auf der Welt
hergestellt ja und dann überlegt man
sich wie man das Töten noch weiter
perfektionieren und noch gräslicheren
Schaden anrichten kann und so
weiter unglaublich unglaublich der ist
ganz hart und die die waren genau auf
dieser Frontlinie da tobte der Krieg da
bricht der Krieg aus und die sind
mittendrin und es gibt in diesem Dorf
das ist ein ziemlich großes Dorf ich ich
ich Schilder Schilder dir mal wier
reingefahren sind wie du fährst rein es
war schon später Nachmittag die Sonne
stand tief es war so ein heißer
Nachmittag und es WTE so ein heißer Wind
über diese steppenartige Landschaft und
du fährst da rein und du siehst diese
sinkende Sonne und du siehst dieses Dorf
und du siehst diese Felder dahinter und
es ist etwas was schönes es würde dir
gefallen jemand der Natur liebt der mag
das der sagt wir kommen jetzt
hier raus aufs Land das ist wunderbar
hier hier wä man gerne und dann dieser
Moment wenn du plötzlich merkst ach so
ne warte mal das ist ja alles ganz ganz
anders du siehst kein einziges Haus das
nicht in irgendeiner Form entweder ganz
zerstört oder teils zerstört wurde dann
fällt dir plötzlich auf gibt ja ja kaum
Menschen es gibt ja auch keinen Laden
dann fährst du an einer Schule vorbei
komplett zerstört du siehst diesen
Spielplatz woden wol noch so ein paar
Gerippe irgendwie rumstehen eine Schule
ohne Dach einfach weggesprengt dann
fährst du weiter dann siehst du
irgendwann so so ein Hund der einfach
deinem Gegenlicht irgendwie auftaucht
dann siehst Du plötzlich ein paar Schafe
ein paar Ziegen und du merkst das sind
ja doch Menschen es ist wie in einem
amerikanischen
Kriegsfilm endzeitfil absolut es ist
Endzeit Max ja ja und dieses dieses
gruseln das kommt dieser dieser Schock
wenn du plötzlich merkst alles das was
du da vermutet hast ist alles falsch das
ist eine eine Illusion das was du
dachtest dass da ist ist da nicht
sondern das ist tod das ist verderben
das ist wirklich Ende und dann kommst Du
da rein und wir waren verabredet mit
einem jungen Bauern Vitali der uns D mal
erzählt hat und ich habe ihm auch gesagt
ich soll dich von einem Freund aus
Deutschland namens Richard fragen wie du
diesen Krieg seehst und D sagt Markus
wie soll ich denn diesen Krieg sehen ich
meine da kommen Menschen die die
zerschießen mir einfach Malin Haus und
dann hat er mal geschildert wie das
passiert ist die haben sich verkrochen
er und seine Familie achtjähriger damals
siebenjähriger Junge seine Eltern seine
Frau er noch ein paar Freunde und
Verwandte in einem Loch in der Erde im
Kartoffelkeller du musst dir vorstellen
wir reden über Februar 22 also der
Beginn des Krieges der Beginn des
Krieges die ersten Wochen in diesem
Keller haben die wochenlang ausgehart
sag ich wir habt i da geheizt ein
feuchtes kaltes Erdloch und sagt ja ich
habe mir vom Trecker eine Batterie
ausgebaut und dann von meinem alten Auto
habe ich da irgendwie eine Heizung und
da raus haben wir uns irgendwie was
gebastelt
einfach also kom und das war ein Mann
der hatte einen BMW auf den war er
wahnsinnig stolz das war ein das war
kein armer Bauer sondern es war ein
vergleichsweise wohlhabender sehr
arbeitssamer fleißiger Mann und dann
sagt dann komme ich dann raus und dann
sehe ich wie dieser russische Panzer auf
uns zurollt und plötzlich dreht er
dieses Geschützrohr und zielt genau auf
mein Haus und dann drückt der Typ der
drin sitzt einfach ab und es macht Kavum
und dieses ganze Haus ist ein
rümerhaufen dann zerstören sie seine
landwirtschaftlichen Maschinen die er
teils vorher gerade neu gekauft hatte
Klammer auf auf Kredit noch gar nicht
abgezahlt die waren kein einziges Mal im
Einsatz sind jetzt schon kaputt so und
dann hocken die da vor den trümern ihrer
Existenz und die erste Frage ist warum
warum haut i nicht ab sagt du ja wir
haben versucht abzuhauen und so weiter
sind dann irgendwann auch abgehauen
wurden beschossen während sie da raus
fahren mit Ihrem Kind dann kommt er
wieder zurück und und und irgendwas zu
retten dann geht er vor Augen in dieses
Trümmerfeld rein und holt sich eine Hose
raus und sagt die habe ich schon länger
vermisst eine meiner Lieblingshosen
zusammen in dieser Bruchbude drin
einfach nur noch nur noch ein
Trümmerfeld und dann sag ich wo sind
deine Tiere weil Bauer zu sein bedeutet
ja auch unabhängig zu sein das ja die
Idee von Bauer sein und der ist komplet
zurückgeworfen auf alles der hat keine
Tiere mehr sagt ich habe meine Kühe
verendet irgendwo dann im Umfeld gesehen
auf mein Feld kann ich nicht mehr raus
weil da liegen überall Minen wenn ich
irgendwie entmene mache ich das selber
irgendwie ganz primitiv zieht er dann
irgendwelchen Seilen dann geht das Ding
in die Luft ja ja es ist irre also das
heißt der Krieg ist für den selbst wenn
die Front sich jetzt weiter bewegt hat
für den ist der Krieg noch lange lange
nicht vorbei und dasenäum ja genau die
Leben von Spenden von von
Hilfsorganisationen der hat sozusagen
sein unabhängiges Leben als Bauer hat er
eingetauscht gegen das Leben eines eines
mittellosen Mannes der mittlerweile se
BMW verkauft hat genau
almosenempfängers der jetzt irgendwie
zusehen muss wier durchkommt und ich kan
auch gar nicht wieder aufbauen ich meine
der Krieg ist ja nicht vorbei do das
macht er das macht er und sag
sein kann inem halben Jahr oder in einem
Jahr kann das wieder zum Schauplatz von
Kriegshandlungen werden genau das das
ist genau der Punkt du du baust es auf
und du weißt gar nicht ob sich das
überhaupt lohnt und dann kommt er wieder
mit einem einzigen Schuss zerstört er
die dein zu Hause und deine Existenz
genau das ja Ehre und der sagt sag mal
seid ihr nicht müde davon müsste man den
nicht irgendwie ein Angebot machen
müsste man nicht irgendwie sagen komm
jetzt nimmt die nimmt die Krim und nimmt
noch ein paar Teile vom Donbass und so
weiter und dann frieren wir das
zumindest ein und dann hört dieses
sinnlose sterben zumindest mal für eine
Weile auf und so weiter der sagt nein
wenn das machen dann kommen die wieder
die die bauen sich wieder auf das haben
die ja schon mehrfach gemacht ja und
diese Haltung das war sehr interessant
jetzt könntest du sagen das ist
anekdotisch du erzählst mir hier etwas
das hast du so erlebt ich habe während
dieser gan Reise und immer noch
anekdotisch gebe ich gerne zu aber ich
habe viele viele Leute gesprochen ganz
zufällig auf der straßefach angesprochen
und diese Haltung war immer glasklar ich
habe einen einzigen alten Mann getroffen
der sagte ich habe mal mit den Russen
ich war da in der Armee und so weiter
und der selenski ist schon auch und die
Amerikaner kam dieser Antiamerikanismus
wieder durch aber ansonsten muss ich dir
sagen sehr klare Haltung die die wissen
da ist ih in ein Krieg aufgezwängt
worden und und wenn sie so weiterleben
wollen wie sie leben die haben alle
diese Berichte im Hinterkopf die kennen
es aus eigenem Erleben zum Teil die
wissen wie brutal die Russen foltern in
jedem Keller die wissen zu welcher
Gewalt die jederzeit bereit sind und die
wollen so nicht leben wen aber die
wichtigste Botschaft die ja die da draus
hervorgeht ist das ja wie auch immer
dieser fürchterliche Krieg zu Ende geht
am Ende ein Frieden stehen muss der der
der genau das wofür wovor vitalie sich
ja zurecht fürchtet ja das ist der der
der Anfang des nächsten Krieges ist
richtig der das grundsätzlich verhindert
und das ist ja das ist ja im Grunden die
große Aufgabe vor der man steht und die
wir ja heute immer damit beantworten
dass wir sagen ja das geht natürlich nur
wenn die Ukraine den Krieg gewinnt da
wir aber gleichzeitig offensichtlich
einsehen müssen dass das so ohne
weiteres nicht passieren wird sind wir
ja in dieser sackkasse aus der wir
gegenwärtig nicht rauskommen richtig
genau und deswegen finde ich auch
interessant ich me all die die
friedensvorschläge die gemacht wurden
von Seiten etwa Südafrikas oder we das
Vatikan oder wie auch immer wir
versuchen ja irgendwie so provisorischen
Zustand erstmal zu machen damit die Luft
rausgeht aus dem Krieg und du hast jetzt
die andere Perspektive beschrieben
nämlich diejenigen derjenigen sagen was
nützt uns so ein provisorischer Frieden
wenn er nur ein Provisorium bleibt genau
genau und das ist eigentlich das worauf
wir unsere unsere ganze
gedankenanstrengungen und sowas ja
eigentlich konzentrieren müssen zu
überlegen wie könnte sowas denn aussehen
wenn die Vorstellung dass die Ukraine
ihre gesamten Gebiete zurückbekommt
unrealistisch ist ich das ist doch
eigentlich die große Denkaufgabe vor der
wir heute stehen
oder ja ich habe ich habe mit mit mit
vielen Leuten noch darüber gesprochen
wie das eigentlich in diesen besetzten
Gebieten so gesehen wird ne weil das
schreitet eine unglaubliche
Russifizierung voran da wird alles get
was in irgendeiner Form Ukrainisch ist
da wird der wird wird die halbe
Bevölkerung einfach systematisch
ausgetauscht da werden Kinder nach
Russland verschleppt und manchmal sehen
die Eltern sie wieder und häufig sehen
sich ja auch nicht wieder und so weiter
du kennst diese traurigen Geschichten
und ähm und dann könnte man ja denken
okay die die dann dort sind die wollen
das nicht aber ich habe
interessanterweise Russen auch getroffen
die wollen nicht von Russen befreit
werden das wollen die nicht das wollen
die nicht die sagen nee nee nee dieses
Russland mit diesem Russland wollen wir
nichts zu tun haben das hat dann auch
noch mal ganz andere Ausprägungen die
die dann zum Teil so sind dass du denkst
uii mit wem haben wir es denn da jetzt
zu tun ich habe gesprochen mit einem
Jungen Mann das ein harter
rechtsradikaler würde ich sagen ziemlich
bekannt auch in der Ukraine das war
einer von denen erinnerst du dich es gab
vor ein paar Wochen die Meldung die asof
Leute wieder da sind nee da ist da ist
so da ist so ein trup von Leuten einfach
rüber nach belgorot in Russland ach ja
ja haben dann dort an so einem
Grenzposten mal richtig aufgeräumt so so
partisanenaktion durchgeführt genau und
sind wieder zurück und dann sagte ich zu
ihm sag mal stimmt es dass sie dann den
den Russen dort äh ein ein gepanzertes
Fahrzeug geklaut hab um wieder
zurückzukommen und er sagte nee das
haben wir natürlich nicht wir haben zwei
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge geklaut weil wir
waren ein paar mehr und wir wollten
nicht wieder zu Fuß zurückgehen und da
hat er dann so lässig so erzählt und
fühlte sich auch ziemlich gut dabei und
stellte sich raus der kam aus
Novosibirsk das waren waren Russe der
dann auf der Seite der Ukraine auf der
Seite der Ukrain Partisan und
Sabotageakte in Russland ver durch genau
der in Russland viele Probleme bekommen
hat weil er tatsächlich ein harter
rechter ist und aber rechts verstehe ich
gerade gar nicht in dem zusammen ja ein
Rechtsradikaler was rechtsradikaler
Russe rechtsradikaler Ukrain
rechtsradikaler Russe rechtsradikaler
Russe erstmal ursprülich rechtsradikaler
Russe genau ich dachte dass die
Rechtsradikalen die Rechtsradikalen
Russen besonders hinter dem Krieg stehen
würden nee alsoedchte je
nationalchuinistischer man istso eher
verteidigt man diesen Krieg also wie sie
kommt ein ein Rechtsradikaler Russe dazu
für die Ukrainer zu arbeiten das begreif
ich überhaupt nicht ich glaube der war
lass es uns vielleicht so sagen mein
mein Gefühl war der war sogar den
supernationalistischen Russen zurechts
und und da geht schon no ein
supernationalistischer Russe unterstützt
oder stützt ja das System in Moskau ja
der ist ja auf der seitenp der nicht der
der sagt dieses ganze System alles Wii
wasashi und die Einwanderung und das
ganze
Thema die arbeiten ja weil die also die
jene Ukraine die auf dem Weg ist sich
nach Westen zu orientieren die findet er
besser ich würde sagen eher Notwehr
Richard also sozusagen bevor du 20 oder
40 Jahre eingebuchtet wirst suchst du
dein Flucht dann dein Heil eher in der
Flucht ins Ausland und das benachbarte
Ausland ist in dem Fall die Ukraine und
dann beginnt da dieser Krieg und dass du
redest hier von Leuten die haben auch
die haben Spaß am Kämpen und tötenner
bezahlt auch ja ich ich ich ich weiß
nicht irgendwas muss ja leben ja ja ja
ja das also die die haben Finanziers im
Hintergrund hat aber nicht wirklich
offengelegt wer die Leute sind äh aber
tatsächlich machen die da so ihre
Sabotageakte das hat aber tatsächlich
mit dem mit dem normalen Ukrainer nichts
zu tun das ist da auch so eine so eine
komische Ausprägung die seltsam ist und
ich habe ihn dann gefragt und sagt der S
mal weil es hat so nebenbei erzählt und
sagte mus diese zwei Fahrzeuge geholt D
sind wirer zurück dann sagte ich du
Entschuldigung ganz kurz ihr geht da
rein ich trefft auf einen russischen
Grenzposten und was sagt die dann das da
stehen ja da stehen ja Leute ich ja und
dann hat ja dann habe ich russisch
gesprochen mit dem die hab mich gefragt
wer wir sind und habe ich auf Russisch
geantwortet dann fühlten die sich in
Sicherheit und dann haben wir sie halt
weggemacht sag die weggemacht und ja
einfach erschossen also den kurzen
Moment der Unaufmerksamkeit genutzt die
die die die Maschinenpistole raus und
die Leute nieder gemätesagt wie viele
sind denn da gestorben meinte ja 40
kannst nicht glauben sagt und dann und
dann sagt das war easy war ganz ein
einfach einfache Sache also da sind so
Rambos unterwegs das ist so brutal wenn
wenn du dir das vorstellst er geht dahin
täuscht die an sagt den pass auf ich bin
einer von euch und dann holt er die wie
im Film in so einem düsteren Kriegsfilm
holt die Kalaschnikow raus und schießt
40 Leute über Haufen du in dem Moment
gedacht oder gefühlt ja ekelhaft ich
meine ist das nicht grausig dass so ein
fürchterlicher krieg ja mit all den
Zerstörung den psychischen den
körperlichen Opfern allem was daz wir
noch unter anderem
das Spaß ma wahrscheinlich gibt auch
unter den fterknechten unter den
fterknechten ich meine wer wird sowas
sonst Leute denen das Spaß macht richtig
also gruselig gr gruselig ja ja ist
gruselig das das ist ja der Punkt und
die diese genau auch dieser haben wir
schon paar mal drüber gesprochen diese
Gewaltbereitschaft dieser Sadismus ja
der ist in einer solchen Brutalität in
dieses Dorf da z.B auch eingebrochen
dass die Leute genau wissen sagen was
sie nicht wollen was sie auf gar keinen
Fall wollen und es gab da weil du schon
gerade Vatikan sagtest Richard wir
hatten da eine Begegnung von der muss
ich dir noch kurz erzählen ich wir
hielten immer som Haus an da waren so
ein paar Jungs stellt i sich dann
hinterher raus die waren so zwischen 20
und 25 und saßen da so im
Garten und ich guckte da so hin und
dachte such den Fehler im Bild und war
sehr schnell zu entdecken weil da saß
ein Typ mit Cowboyhut ja dachte warte
mal Cowboyhut in der südostukraine was
macht er hier stellt sich raus
Amerikaner es waren evangelikale
Christen aus den Vereinigten Staaten
Jungs die dort einfach aus nächsten
Liebe Leuten helfen ihre Häuser wieder
zu reparieren das war ein Handwerker
Dachdecker okay ist sag mal diese
Geschichte ist die schon irgendwie
dokumentiert oder habt ihr die da
aufgespürt wir haben die ja ich habe die
zufällig getroffen ich habe sie
angesprochen ich bin ja dann immer so
unterwegs und frag die Leute ja so
gertruge Style ja sag die einfach und
und wir springen aus dem Auto raus und
dann und drehen sofort und und ich frag
die Leute und dann erfährst du manchmal
unfassbare Sachen das war auch so eine
dieser Geschichten auch ihre Geschichte
ja da steht plötzlich einer vor dir mit
so mit so einem ganz klaren
amerikanischen Akzent und der hat
ukrainische Wurzeln also gibt's
natürlich ein Hintergrund Teil seiner
Familie Mischa heißt er
ist ist ist in in der in der Ukraine
aber die anderen Jungs waren Amerikaner
Freunde von ihm die kam da mich hat das
so beweg wie diese jungen Leute wirklich
nette Jungs die waren abends dann haben
s uns eingeladen zum Volleyball spielen
wir hatten keine Zeit dafür leider aber
ich hätte so gerne gemacht die Jungs
leben in einem Haus
dort das war krass Richard da standen
wir und ich sag zu dem sag was ist denn
das eigentlich für ein Haus was weißt du
denn über die Leute die hier gelebt
haben sagt er ja da war eine Familie mit
einem kleinen Kind und es hatte kurz vor
dem Krieg Geburtstag und wenn du dich
jetzt umdrehst siehst du in dem
Kinderzimmer hingen noch die zerplatzten
Luftballons von diesem Kindergeburtstag
und die hingen dann da in diesem
zerstörten Haus das das hat mich so
angefasst we wir haben selber Kinder wir
wissen was das bedeutet und die haben
Sie einfach alle verjagt und einfach
alle vertrieben und die nutzen das jetzt
dort haben sich so eine kleine Küche
eingerichtet Leben auf dem Boden leben
ganz ganz primitiv aber es war ein
wunderschöner harmonischer weil
empatischer Moment der plötzlich
sozusagen so hart kontrastierte mit
dieser
ander se diese Jungs da die ein sagen
weß wir haben keine große politische
Message wir wir haben auch keinen großen
Plan wir werden helfen genau wir helfen
den Leuten ihre Dächer wieder aufzubauen
und die freuen sich darüber und dann
sagte ich zu ihm du wer war denn hier
während dieses Krieges D mein er ja da
ein alter Mann der war die ganze Zeit
hier das ist der Nachbar da hinten haben
wir leider nicht angetroffen war nicht
da und er sagte der hat über überlebt
weil er eine Kuh hatte und diese
Kuh war sozusagen seine
Überlebensgarantie die Russen wollten
Milch und er hat diese Kuh gemolken und
im Austausch gegen die Milch haben sie
ih am Leben gelassen und ihm so ein paar
Konservenbüchsen gegeben so hat er
durchgehalten da das war so krass
während der der andere Bauer hier Vitali
der dem haben sie alles weggebombt die
Kühe alle tot der einzige der
zurückgekommen ist nach Wochen war der
Hofhund der war da auch den sieht man
auch in dieser Reportage so ein
schwarzer schöner knull er Hund der die
ganze Zeit irgendwie so so rumschmusen
wollte der irendwie dein Bedürfnis nach
Nähe hatte und du siehst wie dieser
Krieg sogar bis bis zu den Tieren hin
einfach mit allem was macht das lässt
einfach nichts unberührt hart und das ja
wie man an diesen Geschichten sieht ja
einerseits das Schlimmste aus vielen
Menschen hervorholt und das Beste aber
in anderen Situationen wenn es wirklich
hart auf hart kommt das beste genau das
ist eh für mich so das irgendwie
unbegreiflichste in dieser ganzen
Geschichte wie sehr Menschen in der Lage
sind sich gerade zu machen zu kämpfen
für ihre Ideale für ihre Überzeugungen
weiterzumachen und so unendlich fest
daran glauben dass es irgendwann besser
wird und das ist das was dir im Leben
hält mhm aber natürlich siehst du auch
und das versteht man dann auch ne da
kämpfen arme Leute gegen arme Leute das
sind diese völlig von der Propaganda
missbrauchten ungebildeten russischen
Soldaten dem man ich weiß nicht was
erzählt hat dass sie dann zu dieser
Gewalt bereit sind weil sie glauben sie
kämpfen da für eine gute Sache gegen
ganz ganz schlimme Nazis sind von
Propaganda und Alkohol und Drogen
spielen auch eine große Rolle Krieg
zweitenrieg genau und und und die werden
missbraucht die werden brutalst
missbraucht und und genauso ne triffst
du dann auch auf andere arme Leute und
so weiter und die ich meine das ist doch
überhaupt ist das nicht immer im Krieg
so dass arme Leute gegen arme Leute
kämfen ja das versteht man dann dort
auch noch mal mir war das
wohabenden genau das haben nicht ihre
Kinder an der Front genau die haben Wege
um sichuszuzien das gilt für die
hochrangigen Politiker für die für die
führenden Wirtschaftsleute und so weiter
deren Kinder sind im Regelfall im
auslandau ja und es hat auch manchmal
ganz praktische Gründe ne ganz
praktische Gründe wenn du an gebildeter
junger itiler bist dann bist du in der
Ukraine dann dann arbeitest du mit
drohen dann bist du irgendwo im hinter
und arbeitest mitohen we da wirst du
gebraucht kan besser richtig da bist du
nicht der arme Infanterist der dann
direkt nach vorne geht und der einfach
wo es dann einfach wo 50% also
Infanteristen ich habe meine Statistik
gelesen also durchschnittlich
Überlebensdauer 60 Sekunden so wenn der
rausgeht es ist einfach irre also wenn
er direkt unmittelbar in ersten
Grundlinie rausgeht gen genau und so
sieht auch aus wenn diese Gräber siehst
wenn du diese militärfriedhöfe siehst
gesehen ja ja wir waren da das ist irre
da gibt es Leute da gibt es Gräber mit
Nummern weil du gar nicht weißt wer oder
was da eigentlich genau drunter ist ja
was V allen Dingen ne wie viel Prozent
von dem was mal ein Mensch war ja genau
und wir haben eine Frau getroffen in in
Odessa da gibt's so ein Ort ein Denkmal
da stand mal Katharina die Große drauf
das haben sie alles runtergeholt das ist
äh ne nichts mehr soll an irgendwie an
an Russen erinnern und das ist so zu
einer Art pilgerstätt auch für junge
Leute geworden die sagen sollten wir uns
mal angucken das ist interessant er wäht
jetzt oben drauf die ukrainische Fahne
die haben alle einen solchen Hass auf
Russland und dann kommt da eine Frau mit
einem Bild eines Mannes und weint
bitterlich und ich bin dit der ins
Gespräch gekommen und dachte okay der
ist jetzt gerade letzte Woche gefallen
ist aber nicht der ist schon vor einem
Jahr gestorben und die ist bis heute
nicht ansatzweise in der Lage das zu
verarbeiten das war so hart das zu sehen
und nichts tröstet sie einfach nichts
weil ist unwiderbringlich ja
ich frage mich bei all diesen grausigen
Schilderungen die Du da machst ne das wä
ja immer du hast das ja vorhin selber
gesagt Menschen müssen optimistisch sein
müssen in die Zukunft gucken genau wie
könnte überhaupt ein Zustand in der
Zukunft nicht in der nahen in der
mittleren oder längerfristigen Zukunft
aussehen dass der Hass der da zwischen
diesen Völkern entstanden ist in diesem
barbarischen Krieg dass der wieder
halbwegs
verschwindetm was müsste da DAF
passieren wie lässt sich das was hier
angerichtet worden ist überhaupt wieder
gut machen also gut machen ohnehin nicht
aber sozusagen halbwegs vergessen machen
oder durch durch irgendwas anderes
überlagert werden oder was auch immer
weil es kann ja nicht dauerhaft sein
dass hier an dem Punkt wo jetzt im
Augenblick die Front verläuft und sei es
50 km weiter östlich oder 50 km weiter
westlich sozusagen der blanke Hass ja
dauerhaft aufeinander trifft weil das
würde dann bedeuten dass es dort keine
Ruhe gibt und D dann nur die Vorstufe
ist für den nächsten Krieg wie soll das
jetzt wieder wegen wenn in den
russischen Gebieten gnadenlos
russifiziert wird wenn auf der anderen
Seite in der Ukraine alles russische per
se verteufelt wird und aus dem
öffentlichen Diskurs verschwindet die
Sprache nicht mehr unterrichtet werden
darf die Bibliotheken gesäubert werden
von russischen bücherern wie wird das
jemals rückgängig gemacht ja ja ich ich
will weil die Frage gar nicht
beantworten weil ich nicht kann ist ja
auch nur rorische Frage du hast völlig
recht Richard ich was was so was ich
auch nicht wusste ist Moderatoren
berühmte Sänger in der Ukraine
Fernsehleute und so weiter die haben
häufig russisch gesprochen im im in
ihrer Arbeit im Alltag ja das war so
fiftyfifty Russland war war war da und
Russisch war eine Realität und
Kinder wurden teils auf russische
Schulen geschickt und so weiter das
heißt man verliert da jetzt auch
sozusagen ein ein ein Teil von Kultur ne
das ist das ist auch d eig eine eig
richtig und ich als als als Südtiroler
tatsächlich kann ich das wirklich sagen
ja
also nach dem nach also speziell unter
Mussolini Südtirol sollte italianisiert
werden und das haben die auch gemacht
also ich ich habe da ganz viele
Parallelen immer so im Hinterkopf ne
wenn ich das sehe denke immer boah ist
die Geschichte meiner Eltern die
Geschichte meiner Großeltern die hier
stattfindet wir hatten sie kleiner die
haben sie unendlich viel größer aber ist
nichts anderes und und wenn ich mir
überlege was die Südtiroler gemacht
haben um diese deutsche Kultur diese
Tiroler Kultur nicht vergessen zu
lassen ne da da rührst du an Punkte der
Identität da du nimmst an den Menschen
die Sprache und es ist vorbei dann bist
du jemand anderer und ich habe das
damals beim es sind Nationen die sich
anmaßen den Menschen vorzuschreiben was
ihre gefühlte Identität ist ja auf beid
Seiten ja und jeder jeder es gibt ja
viele Leute die uns zuhören die selber
mal länger auch im Ausland waren und so
weiter ich weiß noch als ich damals
jetzt mal ohne Scherz gemeint beim
Militär war ja in in in Süd in
Süditalien nach einem halben Jahr habe
ich angefangen wirklich Italienisch zu
träumen und dann habe ich mich dabei
ertappt wie ich ganz anders gestikuliert
habe plötzlich und so weiter das heißt
ich war jemand anderer ja das ist ich
habe das alles adaptiert das war auch
alles schön ja ich mochte das alles und
so weiter und es hat mich bereichert
kannst du heute noch in dein Talkshows
nutzen die italienische Körpersprache ja
und wenn wenn es die aber von außen auf
gezwängt wird ja das geht natürlich
nicht und dagegen wehren sich Menschen
ja das ist we um die Frage geht wer bist
du eigentlich und das ist einer der
Punkte von denen ich manchmal denke das
haben wir noch gar nicht in seiner
Vollständigkeit erfasst und
diesbezüglich sehr interessant hatte
abschließend in Odessa am Strand da da
ging das ganz normale Strandleben weiter
am am vergangenen Sonntag mit mit mit
der Samstag war's mit unserem producer
mit Juri ein Gespräch und sagt der Juri
erzähl mal warum geht's da wirklich weil
es geht an so ein Krieg wir reden immer
über Identität und Nationalstolz und die
große russische Nation warum geht's denn
da wirklich und sagt es geht um Kohle
also Kohle im übertragenen und Kohle im
buchstäblichen Sinne ja wertvolle
Bodenschätze es geht um um Eisen es geht
um alles mögliche ja der der donbas war
Wert Wert ja genau ist alles wert es
geht um Geld und um nichts anderes und
er sagt dies ja geht auch um Macht und
Einflussbereiche und es geht um
geostrategische ja das war kontrollierst
wer krliert Wehen Atomraketen wer
verteidigt sich diese ganzen Dinge
spielen natürlich auch eine große Rolle
genau und von wegen ich bin ich bin
provoziert worden von der NATO und
Tralala dieser ganze diese ganze
propagandanummer da sonder es geht um
ganz handfeste konkrete Interessen und
dann und dann hat er mir erzählt wie sie
damals 2014 da sagte janukovts ja der
war im Amt Putin freundlich und er sagte
die wollten das machen was sie mit
Belarus gemacht haben die wollten aus
der Ukraine so so ein minirussland
machen und als und da gab es mehrere
Schritte er sagt da wurden wurden
Gesetze erlassen erstmal die sozusagen
die russische Sprache vor allen Dingen
ja Bücher Kultur und so weiter massiv
befördert haben und wir wurden sehr
misstrausch als wir gemerkt haben das
passiert aber nicht im gleichenmaße mit
unserer ukrainischen Kultur mit der
ukrainischen Sprache also wir merkten
wir wir sollen da so langsam langsam
kulturell erstmal übernommen werden da
wurden die misstrauscht und sagt und
dann fing diese harte russische
Propaganda an dann wur wir noch misstrau
und gekippt ist es als janukovic in in
Vilnius glaube ich war es dann sagt pass
auf wir die EU wollen wir nicht wir
richten uns in in Richtung Russland aus
ich habe das etwas anders in Erinnerung
also ich habe in Erinnerung dies
gleiche damals dieses EU
Assoziierungsabkommen abschließen wollte
also ein
annäherungsabkommen an die Europäische
Union was den Russen übel aufgestoßen
ist weil janukovt soweit ich das gesehen
habe die Strategie verfolgt ich muss mit
beiden Seiten gut klarkmen also das war
eigentlich seine Orientierung auf dem
Motto ich will das Geld aus Europa ja
und ich will aber nicht den Unmut der
Russen das war eigentlich janukovic
Strategie also er war keine Marionette
wie Lukaschenko in Weißrussland sondern
eigentlich jemand der auch einen
eigenständigen Weg für die Ukraine gehen
wollte aber ohne die Gefahr eines
Krieges mit Russland zu riskieren um
sich gleichzeitig alle Vorteile von der
EU zu verschaffen so habe ich seine
Politik im verstanden die genau die
Ukraine haben das anders verstanden und
er sagte das war der Moment in dem dann
diese jungen Leute plötzlich auf dem
meit anstanden das war der Moment in dem
sie sich dann haben verprügeln lassen
von dieser von dieser von diesen
Polizisten und Soldaten und so weiter
und das war der Moment in dem das alles
plötzlich kippte und dann kommt der
Einmarsch ja dann kommt der Donbass und
so weiter und dann dann geht das alles
richtig los und das war halt so da
versteht man plötzlich wo das alles so
seine Wurzeln hat und es ist wahnsinnig
schwer das aufzulösen eigentlich gar
nicht aber wir sind uns trotzdem einig
dass es irgendwann aufgelöst werden muss
und dass der Weg zu einer Auflösung
nicht über irgendeine schnelle Lösung
führt sondern über irgendein hybrides
Zwischenstadium was wahrscheinlich
ziemlich lange anhält ich meine bei dem
was du erzählt hast ja nach all den
Verbrechen die da verübt worden sind und
dem Hass dem Hass der sich da
aufgeschaukelt hat ja und dem Leid das
dort angerichtet ist kann es natürlich
jetzt nicht irgendeinen Frieden geben wo
man sagt wir gehen zurück auf Los das
ist ja völlig klar stimmt sondern das
ganze wird vermutlich also anders kann
ich es mir gar nicht vorstellen über
irgendein ziemlich langes Provisorium
gehen über das eine Menge Gras wachsen
muss bis überhaupt vernünftige
annährungsgespräche irgendwie wieder
stattfinden können ja das das ist und
ich hoffe einfach im Interesse sowohl
der Länder wie auch im Interesse der
Welt ja Europas und so weiter dass da
nicht auf Dauer ja ein ein dieser Keil
und diese brandlinie die da entstanden
ist in Zement gegossen wird und wir in
eine neue Phase des Kalten Krieges
kommen weil ich eben der ganz ganz
festen Überzeugung bin die können wir
uns im 21 Jahrhundert nicht mehr leisten
nee es ist es ist wirklich wahr weißt du
was mir Hoffnung macht ist tatsächlich
die die Mentalität der Leute ich habe
wir haben 2018 in Russland längere Zeit
gedreht und wir haben jetzt in der
Ukraine gedreht und aus unserer
westlichen Sicht wden ja auch immer so
ich habe das nie so richtig verstanden
so brüdernationen ja alles Brüder alles
Schwester und so weiter die großen
Russen und die etwas kleineren Ukrainer
und so weiter aber eigentlich gibt's
unendlich viele Beziehungen und beide
Sprachen in werden in der Ukraine
zumindest gesprochen und so weiter also
eigentlich wo ist der große Unterschied
wo ist eigentlich das Thema es gibt
einen riesigen Unterschied in der
Mentalität der Leute ich weiß noch als
wir in Russland gedreht haben auch in
Petersburg es war fast wie auf Kuba die
die die die die Leute wenn sie kritisch
sich äußern ja dann sagen sie so wie man
es auf Kuba sagt so verbrämt durch die
ja so man redet nicht klar in der
Ukraine ja jeder in der Ukraine und dann
da merkt ein ganz klares
Demokratieverständnis auch da
Meinungsfreiheit ich sage das was ich
jetzt sagen möchte ja aber es gibt auch
einen klaren Unterschied aber das fand
ich Inter aus Deutschland kommst aus dem
Westen in die Ukraine dann können die
natürlich ihrem Herzen ganz anders Luft
machen ja und Dinge sagenagen wie seh
sie sozusagen das weiß ich nicht das ist
wahrscheinlich schon eine ganze Ecke
riskanter das in St Petersburg sagen als
in Kiev will nur sagen aber in Kiev hat
das für die Leute ganz offensichtlich
und auch im Rest der Ukraine so haben
wir es erlebt hat das die haben niemand
hat Angst davor du merkst ja sofort
welches gesellschaftliche Klima da
herrscht also das kriegst du ganz
schnell mit das kriegst du in jedem
dieser Länder mit das kriegst du auf
Cuba mit das kriegst du in Russland mit
das das und das kriegst du natürlich
auch damit und ich war über moldaven
mitgekriegt gen KGB gbunkelt wurde ja ja
ja ja genau genau
das ja Richard so viel für heute genau
wir lösen die Probleme der Welt nicht
nein nein aber es war aber wir helfen
wir helfen vielleicht und du mit deinen
Berichten sie einfach vorstellbarer zu
machen ja sie einfach sie einfach quasi
aus der
rauszulösen aus dem technischen Blick
den man darauf hat dieser technische
Blick der wo es um Grenzen geht wo es um
militärisches vorrücken um ein Kilometer
vor und wieder zurück wo es um
Waffensysteme geht das sind ja alles die
dingau die auch sehr weitgehend unsere
Talkshows beherrschen richtig richtig
und hinter alledem verschwindet meistens
das worum es hier tatsächlich geht es
geht nicht um Land es geht nicht um
Grenzen und nicht um Waffensysteme
sondern es geht um die Menschen das ist
genau der entscheidende Punkt
und ein Gedanke noch es ist so unendlich
schön Richard wenn du von diesem fiesen
Alarm geweckt wirst und nach einer
kurzen Sekunde der der
Orientierungslosigkeit merkst ah nee
warte mal ich bin noch zu Hause ich ich
bin i beim Bett kann einfach weiter
schlafen ist alles gut das tut so
unendlich gut seid von Herzen gegönnt ja
ich will nur sagen also geht gar nicht
um mich aber das über so langen Zeitraum
nicht zu haben wenn wenn deine kleine
Welt kein sicherer Ort mehr ist das ein
Albtraum und
ich ist auch völlig in Ordnung dass wir
das als selbstverständlich nehmen aber
ab und zu mal kann man mal drüber
nachdenken rich ja danke dir in diesem
Sinne ja Markus ich de danke dir ja und
auf dass du in der nächsten Nacht gut
schläfst ja genau danke Dir sehr Richard
bis bald ciao
ciao eine Produktion von mhoch2 und
podstars bei OMR im Auftrag des
[Musik]
ztf